[Music]
in World Cup miracle news is this
yesterday how wide it is
I witnessed this yesterday oh the team
Korea lost twice to the worst team on
the planet oh my god
team Mexico what and then they beat the
4-year reigning champs who Germany wow
that's so wrong on so many Marilia what
did I watch was a watching [ __ ] mad
tv you really messed up Oh
submitted by Jeana on Paris by diet
Ramos burka Paris by night it's a
Vietnamese store oh yeah let me show you
it's a variety show and it's like super
long can't believe you're insulted
Vietnamese people like that yeah
it's like their Grammys that happens
twelve times a year Mexico football fans
are hyping up Koreans after they
defeated Germany in the World Cup
dude there were places in LA that will
give them with free tacos the Koreans
yeah dude the Koreans save our asses now
Mexico could advance right yeah you said
that Korea
they you think deep Mexico and that
nobody lost to Mexico twice okay matter
no I got them it isn't mad point is
let's move on I don't know what the
first part is what is right yes no
that's not the point
all right what is it what what is the
point who's Tiffany I don't know the
point is sports make races come together
or hate each other
do Korean people and Mexican people
already like each other enough as it was
this just solidified that bond even
further where Dennis wasn't me at mama
doo doo yeah but the moon with that
orianna's you stupid okay and you know
what mano Korea knows is me hermano
Koreans are my friends Koreans my
brothers the closer than friends oh yeah
brah
I know I made it now dooster know we
didn't make it how love people would
believe you that let me tell you the
information I do know because Bart you
might be right about them beating Mexico
because I didn't read that part but here
it says that the reason why Mexico is so
happy about Korea winning or beating
Germany it was first of all Germany
they've been the World Cup favorites
like they were gonna win like people
thought they were gonna win this year
yeah the one four years in a world
represented so Mexico lost 3 to 0 to
Sweden which meant that Germany had to
beat Korea South Korea to eliminate
Mexico and then move on to the next
round but South Korea dramatically
defeated Germany 2 to 0
kimchi power day so then that's how
Mexico is able able to progress and now
I'm going to show you a compilation of a
lot of people celebrating Mexicans
celebrating
Mexican lady's giving Korea's [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
they combined the flag
[Laughter]
that's amazing
I love the shorts in the boots dude that
is so dope it's amazing like how popular
soccer is everywhere except for the
United States cuz we [ __ ] suck at it
yeah that's exact we weren't even
invited to the World Cup right cause we
suck so bad dude solder to like the
United States is like the ugly stepchild
we just hide we just don't give it any
attention at all but that's also because
we have real sports we got basketball
we got football we got real [ __ ] I think
balls only that's exactly how American
say [ __ ] no one gives a [ __ ] about
football and everyone calls soccer
football yeah that makes more sense
because there's a foot to a [ __ ] ball
yeah why football call football is it
cuz the footballs in a shape of a foot
oh yeah they even went to the Korean
consulate and the embassy South Korean
embassy in Mexico City and they've just
like stormed and everyone's like viva la
chorion oh yeah no it's good yeah
Coriana is my dream Oh Korea no is my
primo no hermanos it's closer than primo
Korea no is my abuela Korea no is my
abuela okay we get it you know Spanish
words but yeah I know is my tacos
[ __ ] no but I'll tell you this though I
watch soccer that [ __ ] was boring as
[ __ ] cuz that [ __ ] takes forever to make
a point but and it looks tiring as [ __ ]
but it's the funnest [ __ ] to play it's
so dramatic gosh it's so fun I I used to
like soccer a lot when I was
kid I think it's just because all the
the auditions and stuff hyped it up in
the Korean church yeah so I loved it too
like I had like the World Cup but
there's a lot of running and stuff oh
yeah I did play this really yeah my
parents put me in software not gonna
leave I'm gonna tell you about this one
[ __ ] in soccer right so I was like I
was a little kid at this time I had to
be like seven or eight but how tall are
you though I was about 200 short Nepali
so this is one [ __ ] girl dude she was
also in my tech fondo class right this
[ __ ] ho would kick through my shin
guards that's how powerful she was oh
yeah every time she would [ __ ] kick
the soccer ball she would make the same
noise for tech mundo so every time she
would come at it she's not even going
for the ball she would go for your shins
huh [ __ ] I forgot her [ __ ] name
Eunice yeah Eunice Jessica one of the
great Kim yeah faith I don't know which
one but she would always make the same
noise I will remember for the rest my
life don't scream every [ __ ] time I
she was like nothing shooter that to
every [ __ ] dude but she was like five
years older than us sama what the [ __ ]
she was doing little kids [ __ ] dumb
[ __ ] there's always that one geek so I
played soccer every day during recess in
a second-hand therapy segment third
grade and there's always those League
folks kids that are always wearing their
like soccer shorts they bring the shin
pads and I'm like damn you're so [ __ ]
serious everyone is just playing and
they're [ __ ] like velcro shoes and
this fall brings out cleats and [ __ ]
what a folk I always wanted to be one of
those I wanted to be one of those guys I
thought I was so cool cuz that movie the
big green remember that oh yeah she was
so dumb I wanted cleats I would be so
jealous of my friends cleats and she'll
be like kind of why your cleats man
meets man you look like a caring about
any sport ever but anything at all or
anything
your family know for sure my dad like
like hearing the girl like that's like
the story of my life and you don't even
watch games with them I mean I would sit
there and I'll just be like what the
hell get it oh you gotta explain it to
you would you explain and you get the
game they're like oh I could be on board
for it yeah I don't know I just I just
have memories of hearing the goal and
then my dad making seafood like Mexican
seafood dishes and then that's my child
but only if you gotta remember from
playing soccer as a kid was that I would
have Shin splits all the time yeah you
guys shin splints as a kid cuz that girl
that would kick my shins apart 24
[ __ ] seven dude Wow
I never felt a shin splint until
recently oh I feel like I guess she's
supposed to walk it feels like little
needles inside yeah Harry
it's your shin like having like
microfracture splintering inside yeah
that's really painful like if you ran on
pavement for a long time Yogesh is
what's instantly oh when you're my size
for sure don't it feel like growing
pains like when you know no it's not a
stretch I never had growing pains I
don't know what that feels like
I had like shin splints so often like I
don't relate to how bad they are when
other people say they live shin splints
I'm like that's cool I got em all the
time he's good like I was big so like
big guys whenever you want on pavement
you guys just puts all the fine if
you're weighed 300 pounds that's true a
big guy you [ __ ] you were 300 pounds I
was like 270 miles close close do we
know you then no I was in college at our
house in Riverside at the instant
noodles of spam every day yep virgin I
was not a virgin at that time Wow David
the creature wanted to have sex it's you
know David's a poem in with the [ __ ]
all right Oh [ __ ] sugar oh we're gonna
bring up some stories now are we three
teaspoons
Marc's load yeah you're disgusting
I'm not embarrassed yeah of course
you're not you [ __ ]
I do like cop sports just bring
communities together though I think
that's like super super cool even like
people that like cuz this whereas FIFA
comes every four years so it's like the
other three years
half the people forget about I'm pretty
sure a lot of people aren't even like
soccer fans but every four years and
what the Olympics you get a chance for
like everyone to come together and
represent your country it's pretty tight
yeah you guys heard a soccer of
hooligans they go and fight during games
and whatever like I'm hurt base like
that's their yeah it's crazy
it looks like [ __ ] grave heart like a
scene from like were the Vikings in the
slightest yeah it's a massive group of
like dudes that come out and just brawl
and then there's crews like I think in
Germany or Russia or whatever but they
strain specifically for the football
yeah and then they dress like in [ __ ]
uniform and [ __ ] like they got matching
like jackets and yeah and then they
train like kickboxing and stuff and they
go in like it's crazy you want to get in
that it sounds like you think let's for
[ __ ] hella train for that dude I like
the peaceful side is like pretending on
the cheerleader yeah nobody yeah
they ask like karate groups and whatever
to help them and [ __ ] so just like
you'll just see rumbles and [ __ ] in the
park and if it's crazy man damn yeah you
got to look that [ __ ] up [ __ ] soccer
hooligan soccer hooligans they sell a
childish ass name to soccer monsters
yeah
[Music]
[Music]